Speaker 1: We have some interesting news on the
fight to remove George Anthony Davis elder Santos
from the House of Representatives. House Democrats
have filed a resolution led by Democratic
Congressman Robert Garcia to expel yes, to expel
Jorge Santos from the House of Representatives.
It is the latest escalation, writes Axios, of
Democrats efforts to punish Santos for the serial
fabrications about his background. I have not
been super familiar with Congressman Robert Garcia
up until now. He has an unbelievable sense of
timing. Listen to this interview in which he says,
you know, Santos is a lot like me, Latino, gay,
except he lies about everything. This is so funny.
Speaker 5: As an openly gay person, as an
immigrant, as a Latino. I look at Mr. Santos
as someone who is actually very similar to
me, except that he lies about everything.
And so within within our own LGBTQ community,
there's like major disgust in what he's doing
and his representation of our community. And
so it's not acceptable for him to lie about
every single part of his past, including now
getting classified information or access to it.
So it's just it's time that honest. The final
straw was getting access to giving, actually
being given access to classified information. He
was literally getting someone as a primary wire
access to America's secrets in the media.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, of course, I agree
completely with Robert Garcia. I would not. A few
of you emailed me after the story broke and said,
David, this is such a waste of time. Republicans
control the House of Representatives. There is
just no way in hell that this goes anywhere.
You know, you're probably right. But it is
true that there are some Republicans who are
disgusted by Jorge Santos, and they've said it.
If Mitt Romney were in the House of
Representatives rather than the Senate,
I am 100% sure that Romney would join Democrats
in a vote to remove George Santos. So because the
majority for Republicans is quite small, it is not
completely out of the question that you find that
Democrats find just enough Republicans to maybe
get rid of George Santos. Do I think it's the most
likely outcome? No. But is this worth doing and
try to get a vote and try to get Republicans on
the record, get them to say, no, I vote for Santos
to stay. I actually do think it's a good idea in
this particular case. Now, I am not someone who,
as a blanket says, symbolic votes in the House
are either worth it or not worth that wastes of
time or good uses of time. I don't have a generic
umbrella view on that. I am balancing in my
assessment. Is it really guaranteed to be symbolic
only or is there actually a chance that you might
pass it? What would we achieve by putting members
on the record, by getting them to vote one way
or another? You know, when we think back to that
force, the vote, Medicare for All thing, we
really knew the positions of basically every
every member of Congress on that issue. I actually
don't know the positions of every member of the
House on whether they would vote to keep or expel
George Santos. And it actually is a close enough
margin now that it that at least theoretically it
could work. I think this is an interesting idea.
Good for Robert Garcia, Good for Democrats.
Let's see if we ultimately get a vote on it